[Music]
thank you for coming here migrating on
to Google cloud platform is a journey
and with any great journey it starts
with a single step now if you're here if
you're sitting here planning to think
about that first step or if you're
running a marathon on the GCP world
I hope unities experience over here
would give you some of the insights on
what's to come although I will touch
upon the overall migration of unity onto
GCP but the focus of our talk today is
on the networking piece of the whole
migration but before I jump in I do want
to take this opportunity to introduce
ourselves
Arielle who is the lead networking
architect at Unity
she's been closely involved not just
with the migration of networking on to
GCP but also running the work for
workloads on GCP ever since we migrated
her perspective as a customer of GCP is
very valuable because she brings a very
different perspective which is your
perspective to the whole story Thank You
Ariel for being here and sharing her
stories with us it takes two hands to
clap
I have Davis here who has our networking
engineer from Google
he's been the backbone of the migration
from a Google site and today he's going
to bring the googles point of view to
the whole migration and probably share
some insight scoops on the migration I
am Anand I'm the Technical Account
Manager for unity from Google along with
my team of engineers and consultants I'm
responsible to make sure that unity is
successful on GCP in short voice of
Google in unity and voice of unity at
Google if you have any questions during
this session we're using Dory Q&A please
do go on to your next app click on this
session you will find a link for Dory
Q&A please do write your questions in
there
you cannot port questions that you think
you want to be answered over here if
you're not able to answer any questions
we'll definitely get back on the Dory
Q&A with the answers all right before we
dive into any of the details over here
for those of you who don't know what or
who Unity Technologies is unity is a big
game a big name in the gaming industry
it's it's been it's among among other
things that unity is known for it's
known for its unity gaming engine which
is a platform that helps game developers
build games Assassin's Creed Pokemon go
are some of the many many games that
have been built on unity itself they've
had more than 29 billion installs you
have a nine billion installs of unity
experience the last year if you think
about it it's about 3.5 times the
population of the world they are a key
player in the AR VR and the mobile games
industry at Google our vision is to
create connect and scale games we've had
the greatest of Google products invested
in this vision and together we're trying
to make sure the gaming part at Google
is successful with the addition of
stadia into our arsenal I am very
excited to see how the space turns in
the future now what happens when you
bring two big names together magic along
with with Google and unity have been
partnering on multiple fronts to make
gaming experience more rich and more
inclusive for everyone we have my we
have a bunch of sessions during next
that talk about various initiatives that
have come out of this such as connected
games matchmaker I would highly
encourage you to attend those sessions
but before all this magic actually
happens
unity had to get onto the Google cloud
platform and that's where the journey
actually started with a scale of unity
we had to do this quick and we had to
get this right
unity had offices
the globe and we had to make sure that
each of these officers the workloads
running out of them had to be migrated
onto Google cloud platform mitre my team
was entrusted with the task to make sure
that this migration is successful the
PSO are the professional service
organization is a team of technical
account managers engineers and
consultants that work on ensuring that
customers such as unity can accelerate
as soon as possible on the Google cloud
platform
we are spread globally and quite
effectively that way long story short in
a span of six months we were able to
successfully migrated unity on to the
Google cloud platform now you not get a
we're not gonna get into the nitty
gritties of the migration if you are
interested again there's another session
tomorrow that talks about this in quite
detail there you go so here we are after
the migration unity has been using a
whole host of Google cloud products
right from compute all the way to cloud
AI but the focus of today's talk we're
gonna deep dive into the networking
components that we have along with with
Davis and Ariel we're going to talk
about some of the experiences challenges
decisions and hacks both on the unity
and the Google side that we made on
making sure all these products were
onboard and are successfully running at
the moment we're going to take a quick
peek into the networking world of unity
they're going to share our experiences
on the migration phase itself and the
processes that were put in place for
post migration to ensure that unities
unities networking workloads do are set
up for success on GCP are you once again
thanks for sharing your experiences on
this of course my pleasure and I hope
sharing our experiences here can be
helpful to the audience here so before
we dive into the network architecture of
app unity in TCP I want to run through
some characteristics
and requirement of our infrastructure so
we have a hybrid infrastructure so we
have some small footprint in data center
physical location and most of a muscle
fiber workload running in public cloud
and our infrastructure is not only
multiple span across multiple region is
also span across multiple clouds father
backbone is primarily IPSec based but
for Sam workload between certain
environments we do have the requirement
to have much higher capacity bandwidth
requirements where multiple of IPSec
tunnels are not going to to meet the
requirement and also a V infrastructure
have very high growth rate so our design
in TCP need to be able to scale so with
that in mind when we start up a journey
in GCP start the build in 2018 we work
with the Google team and quickly come up
with a set of key architecture decisions
those decisions then later on play the
key factor in to determine the phenol
TCP a network build so first we work
with the Google team we decided to use
one vp c for transitive routing between
TCP and that the other cloud
infrastructure we have and also we know
that especially during the migration we
will need some partner interconnect
based the product to link between the
environment the certain environments to
provide much higher bandwidth and also
we decided to use global routing versus
regional routing the reason being is
because with the collaborating we will
be able to do failover between regions
hands increase our network availability
also we decided to use cloud routers so
our team do have the experience to man
to use over the shelf virtual routing
and encryption equipment and also we
have the experience of management
linux-based the open source routing and
encryption processes however we choose
to use cloud router because it's purely
API driven and it may have nation
super-easy and also we decided to to put
a some workload into share of a PC
architecture the reason to use shared of
a PC architecture is because used
architecture it allows us to aggregate
all of workload into a fewer VDC hence
reduce the ongoing operational cost so
equip it with those key decisions we
dived into the PLC pretty quickly and
it's there
many lesson learned and there's
something I specific specifically
related with routing I want to share
with the audience here so the first
snack we had we try to do transit of a
PC is the interoperability between c.src
ADA bus and the the cloud routers in GCP
so the CSR seen a Tobias behind the
night IP address so by default when he's
trying to negotiate I can do the ika
negotiation in a while use is the VMS
private IP as the local identity and
that caused the cloud not cloud router
the VPN in Google site to reject I key
in causation so the fix is very simple
the fix is to have a one line of command
in cisco csr and a ke where you can
specify to use the public nine IP of the
cisco CSR as the local identity for IKEA
negotiation so with that we continue to
look into the routing expect of the
transit VPC for routing we use clock
router cloud router for me is like the
vgw in a Tobias world in a sense that it
provides functionality to allow dynamic
routing exchange using PGP
as well as it have the ability to
to propagate the route to program the
route into the VP CEO subnet however
there is one key behavior difference
there so if cloud router they don't
really automatically reduce redistribute
the pass throughout the BGP route
between the BGP peers and also we notice
that when as we learn more about GCP we
realized we need to do route
summarization reason being is there are
certain limits you need to be aware of
their limits there is a limit about how
many prefixes you can announce through a
PG beep here and there is a limit on how
many prefixes unique prefixes you can
program into your with BBC in DCP so to
do route summarization we choose to use
customer routes and you can do customer
routes on the per cloud router level or
pervade Heon level the BT peer level and
also when while we start to experiment
and doom POC about this transit VGC idea
we learn that there is a need for to set
of clouters in each region for
transitive routing to give more color on
that so this is a simplified diagram on
our initial plc where we will have ones
cloud routers in the middle part of a
portion which is a transitory PC that is
Claira router have have a BGP
relationship with SSRC ADA bus and also
it have BGP relationship with the
environment one VPC which we call it
downstream VPC and that cloud router
intransitive V PC will learn a prefix
one from a device from the csr and we
use customer routes and hope that the
customer routes will then be read virtus
into a variant one v pc but that's not
the case so in the end we have to use to
color routers so in the transit V PC we
have cloud rot one club routed to
Colorado one is used to receive the
prefix from the
CSR and then the cloud router will then
program the route
the proof the route into the transit VPC
routing table and clout rather to on
Colorado - we are then used customer
route to announce the prefix 1 into the
environment 1 VPC cloud router by doing
routing this way will all be able to do
transit routing between eight of us and
the environment 1 the pc so now here is
the diagram it shows our routing with
more detail so the middle section is the
transit VPC and in transit VPC we have
color routers in different regions in
each region we have a set of cloud
routers for one plus one redundancy for
connectivity and change exchange routes
with the CI SARS in a device and also we
have a set of transit cloud cloud
routers for route exchange with the
environment with the PC color routers
there and also within the transit of a
PC we use global routing with global
routing enabled each of the caliber out
the cloud router will have a global
route of view of the whole VPC what it
means that if for example we have the
PGP OB GP fail within region 1 and the
workload in the environment 1 EPC will
still be able to reroute it through the
nearest the region to reach a device and
also here I want you will see the both
hi star of connectivity I want to stress
that it only represents than to the the
control path for rotting selection so
for actual data paths it goes through
the VPN gateway so for VPN gateway we
can scale horizontally as we need
and now let's look into how we do
networking inside the environment VPC so
we use share of a PC this in this
diagram on the top you will see a share
VP Singh in a host project in a share of
a PC you will see that we'll have clout
routers in many different regions and
then from that cloud router we have
connectivity to the upstream transit
transit VPC and also in a shared VPC we
create a subnet in d-formation and then
we share the permission to use the
subnet with the maintainer of different
resources in the service projects so for
our development team they know if they
get a subnet from us from the share PPC
if access control permits they will be
able to reach to the add workload
regardless of which region that workload
is in and which infrastructure that
workload is in so this is how how we do
networking in unity in GCP but there are
many other options that you can use to
connect different VPS and infrastructure
together
so next davis do you want to go through
those options
absolutely thanks Cyril for walking us
through
Unity's network architecture as well as
highlighting a few of the caveats you
mentioned now at this point I want us to
take a step back because I want to
highlight what are the different design
options for interconnecting Vee PCs and
Google cloud so unity leveraged VPNs but
based on a use case you could leverage
different design options so with I'm and
for each option I'm gonna highlight the
advantages and disadvantage of a PCS so
when you leverage VPNs the major
advantages that it gives is it enables
transitive topologies if you're using
static route based VPNs and if you need
dynamic route based VPNs you
have to use to cloud routers as
mentioned earlier by arielle secondly
you can scale the number of VPN tunnels
if you need higher bandwidth and also
the choice of the tunnel is based on a
fight Apple hash it is a managed service
and as an SLA of three nines now what
are the considerations with VPNs each
VPN tunnel has about 1.5 gigs over
public Internet so you can of course
scale with adding more tunnels and also
you need to account for the IPSec
headers right so on the remote end on
your on-prem router maybe you have to
configure 14 60 bytes for your Ethernet
empty you
this results in our decrease in the
maximum segment size and hence less are
good but something to be aware of and
finally I'm sure at least few of you in
the audience if you have ever created an
IPSec tunnel would have troubleshooted
eye crease one face two negotiation so
there is a little bit of overhead and
and management which constraints so the
next approach for interconnecting Vee
pcs is by leveraging a multi Nick V M
where each network interface goes to a
distinct V PC in the project so this is
a typical as illustrated in this diagram
so this is a design option that you
would leverage when you need all your
traffic to go through an appliance like
a next-generation firewall that does
deep packet inspection now with this
approach what are the major advantages
right so each core or V CPU of the VM
has a peak performance of two gigs and
if you leverage 8 course you get 16 gigs
but adding more than eight won't give
you higher throughput so but this is
again shouldn't change you can also
scale through management since group and
I saw ecmp routes the major
considerations involved that each VM can
have a maximum of 8 mix meaning you can
interconnect maximum 8p pcs
all these V pcs must belong in the same
project and today load-balancing is only
supported on Nik 0 and for Nanak 0 you
would have to leverage GCP static routes
and ecmp across them that is by having
multiple static routes with equal
priority the final approach for
interconnecting V pcs is by leveraging V
PC peering where you appear to be PCs
using Google's Sdn clean so these V pcs
can be in different projects in the same
organization or it could be across
different organization so here is V PC
appearing with be PCP in the diagram so
the major advantages is it's very high
bandwidth right it's as if all the V pcs
in the peering group is a single V PC
it's very easy configuration all you
need to state is the project ID as well
as a remote V PC you wanna P of it and
that's pretty much it and you have
granular control as to the number of as
to the custom routes the dynamic and
Static routes you wanna import and
export now what are the major
considerations so it is non transitive
so if you take if V PC appears with B
and C B and C cannot communicate with
each other they have to be directly
connected also something to be aware of
when you operate at very large scale is
that certain quotas certain resource
quarters are aggregated across all the V
pcs in the peering group just to name a
few
is the VM count and internal forwarding
rules so I hope highlighting the
advantages and considerations will help
you make better decisions Isis with your
design network design and GCP now moving
back coming back to unity is network
journey right certain key efforts were
taken by the teams to onboard internal
customers into a completely new platform
also tooling was developed by the infra
Emad unity in
order to easily enable customers to use
a shared way PC and I'll have Ariel to
speak more more on this all right so
after we built the network we spend a
lot of effort to Bob onboard our
internal customers and it's a big effort
and it's effort actually across many
different teams not just us so first we
ran a lot of am boarding related
presentations we have the presentation
with different customers in different
regions and in presentation we focus on
describe to the customer what's the new
architecture in DCP what's the
characteristics of our network such as
what the penguin supported what they can
expect in terms of bandwidth between
different environments what's the
latency and what's the service level
objectives that we use to come up with
the with the network design and those
informations are very important for our
development teams to be able to
eventually come up with their migration
strategy that can be supported by the
underlying infrastructure we also
created a GCP kickstart guide is a guide
that provided step-by-step instructions
on how to start in DCP such as how to
create a project how to you access to
the project how to be able to share
permissions with the other team members
and we also created a portal for project
creation it's not as simple as just
create a project it's actually a suite
of actions it will create a project and
even if the project requires access to
use the share of a PC it will then be
attached to have host projects and also
it will delete things like the default
network and create relates like relevant
service accounts and we also create a
portal for firewall roll request
it's a GUI driven
and turns out we didn't have the very
high adoption rate as we hoped because
most of our developers like to write
infrastructure in code although it
proved to be very useful to some teams
and some people and then we decided to
share our share of a terraform repos on
subnets and foul rules with the
development team and to do that we used
her phone terraform modules but never
deaths that make sense to enforce a
certain standard and templates and also
we found is really useful to install
some linters the linters we installed
for in our perform CD pipeline it allows
us to be able to verify and qualify a
merge request before a human come to
review the merge request what it does is
for example it will check if the format
is right if there is an in syntax errors
or if there any variables used that are
not declared also it will check that for
example for our rules in will check if
the forward roll name is more than 63
character which typically you are all
only notice that at the time of the
terraform apply and it will be able to
expose to you because Google API I will
give your error but without linter we
can detect those errors up front and
using these measures and tactics that it
helped us to unboard our customers spend
across different geo locations without
us being the bottleneck as we on board
customer we also start to work on the
network monitoring and logging because
we want to make sure we had a visibility
of our network health within GCP as
customers that you have internal
customers that you iterate within tcp so
we have our own in-house monitoring
implementation with the help from our
monitoring and logging team we quickly
implemented some backbone
backbone connectivity monitoring it will
monitor the connectivity on the latency
and availability between different
environments within GCP and also GCP we
also use our in-house monitoring for
metric gathering of some VMs running
network services such as network address
translation and we also heavily utilize
a stack driver login and monitoring
especially for elements such as the
Google VPN gateway or Google cloud
routers so speak of stackdriver Davis do
you want to give us some examples on how
to mind the cloud router events using
spec driver logging absolutely yep
thanks serial so I'm going to walk
through few examples of using Strack
driver log inquiries to determine cloud
route events right so the first one is
when a cloud router is being upgraded or
migrated so this is usually even since
cloud router is a fully managed service
right it does undergo upgrades and
patches right and these upgrades are
completed in less than 60 seconds the
old on timer is 60 seconds meaning
traffic forwarding and should not be
affected and as the routes are preserved
so what you need to look out for is not
sure if it's clear
so essentially you go to cloud console
and then you hit logging start over
logging logs and you convert into an
advanced filter where you search for a
source type GCE router and look for the
keyword task activated so this is
something that you should track this is
an event that you should track next is
something an event of when a bgp peering
goes down right so this is essentially a
network outage if you don't have written
in C in place so a critical event to
look out for what what happens is you
just need to you need to look for the
keywords bgp peering and went down and
as you can see here 1.6 the neighbor 1.6
has gone gone down at that particular
time stamp and immediately after the
neighbor goes down well
the routes are going to be evicted from
the BBC table and what do you look for
in this case is the route route event
and deleted from from the cloud out so
as you can see here 10200 slash 24 is
being evicted from the same router who's
peering session went down earlier from
the earlier slide so this is essentially
I just wanted to give you a glimpse of
how you could use stack travel log in
queries now what do you do with these
right so you could export it into pops
up and a pops up topic and you as as
these events occur you could trigger a
cloud function that executes an API for
remediation so so that is kind of the
capability of stock travel and well I
now want to kind of focus on a
particular network service which is
network address translation the reason I
bring this up is because there are a few
considerations with its implementation
and I believe it will be useful to you
to be aware of it so firstly there I
there two approaches right to
implementing that in GCP the first one
is self managed not where you run a VM
where not software or maybe a Linux VM
doing IP tables for not functionality so
what are the considerations with this
approach you need a monitor the VM for
scale as well as for Lord you need to
create certain scripts to do this second
it I cannot stress enough on this it
breaks Google private access so now what
what is private access it's basically
private VMs having the capability to
make API GCP API calls and services
through Google's backbone this is made
possible using a default route with the
next stop as default internet gateway so
when you override that route and you
state default when you create a default
route with next off as nat instance all
your traffic is going to go through in
our instance and I've been and it
overloads an ad and you might bring down
the not instance so I've been on many
troubleshooting calls
essentially fixing this so I I think you
should yeah it's an important caveat to
note
next is at the same point I mentioned
earlier with multi Nick Williams its HP
CPU as about two gigs or peak
performance and as you use it once you
get 16 gigs as Max for peak performance
now what is cloud nut and how does this
help at all well it is Google managed
service it has an SLA of three nines
it is highly available as well as other
scales without any user prevention
intervention or management right the
perks of running a managed service now
private Google access automatically
works and your bandwidth is azov your
VMs that need to be your private games
that need to be knotted having an
external IP so essentially huge
performance benefits concentration so
cloud NAT does not support application
level gateways what this what this means
as certain protocols like sip and F FTP
they require the IP in the application
PDU to be knotted also so cloud that
does not have that functionality today
logging is an alpha and also finally
only anomic so when you when you create
cloud not you have to specify the
maximum maximum number of ports which
are available to each VM so if you say
64 ports by default at 64 ports so if
you say 64 ports available to each VM
formatting purposes and the VM
essentially makes a large number of
connections to the same destination IP
and port which is over 64 then the
packets are going to be no then the trap
packet is not going to be knotted so you
need to kind of plan what subnets or
what work streams need to be need what
what streams need to be made available
for cloud not and I think Ariel will
share experience on its implementation
at unity
so for our unity not implementation when
I first started back in early 2018 our
choice is very simple because there is
no cloud net available so we created
many net clusters we have one net
cluster in each region and each
environment and also we use route tags
to route route tax and then provide
those texts who have a development team
so the development team can use these
tags once it's applied to a VM it will
routes the Internet traffic we see - the
internet the traffic goes to prefix of
zero zero zero slash zero what we wrote
is through the relevant in that cluster
so it works well at the very beginning
however late in the migration we start
notice that occasionally our net night
clusters may get overwhelmed and this is
the usage graph and it shows you can see
that the traffic pattern can be ready
spiking and there are times when we can
have and this is only a support for one
environment and one region we have and
at times where I'll see traffic goes
from four point something gigabit per
second to 40 plus GB per second within
five minutes and when we look deeper we
notice most of majority of this traffic
actually not the traffic go through the
public internet a lot of the traffic is
actually goes through the Google pop up
Google API services like GC is so GCR
and then you know we luckily I had some
ways that we experienced this issue
cloud net is already gone when GA but
before we immediately jump into the
cloud net implementation we look at
several different options we look at
option where we can possibly inject more
specific routes in the routing table for
certain Google api's to route those
traffic's through the Google Internet
gateway
that allows private cocoa access we also
look at look at these reefs restricted
Google API access feature but we have
some concerns about how to do the the
dmoz in using that feature and
eventually after some analysis we
decided google cloud net is the
direction we should be we should go so
when we started looking to migrate
workloads into cloud net the first
question we asked ourselves what ad
workload we should be focusing on in
migrating to cloud net at a time our net
clusters occasionally get overwhelmed we
want to be able to stabilize our service
so in order to find the top talker what
we did is to utilize the the flow logs
so we enable flow logs for the subnet
where our net devices uses and then we
send those flow logs into bigquery and
with a fairly simple query query we'll
all be able to find the top talkers so
identify the top talkers allows us to
figure out which development team which
we then should collaborate with to
migrate those traffic into cloud net and
then the second question we ask
ourselves is how to qualify if a
workload is a good candidate for cloud
net because of the caveats that Davis
mentioned before when you create a cloud
net you do have a to actually put a
number for a maximum concurrent
connection a VM can establish to a
destination IP and port combination so
what we don't what we don't want is to
migrate something jumping to cloud nine
Megara to cloud net and potentially have
workload experience selling failures
that because over the port exhaustion so
what we did is to first we look into you
know basically mind the flow locks we
have in the query but for some reason we
find that we can't really fire
all the all the flows that for one
particular stream before it goes into
the net athlete come out of that get
netted and come back and eventually back
to the VM and maybe that's because of
the sampling we didn't look further but
we'll quickly develop another method so
with other team members that you pick
snapshot of all the connection tracking
tables across all the net devices within
one cluster and then we have a little
simple goal client that go client
basically inject all these connection
tracking table information and pass it
and then send it stream it into bigquery
with this message we basically gain the
real-time visibility into the
characteristics of all our traffic that
outbound to the Internet and this allows
us to be able to tell by looking into a
subnet normally correlates to one
workload it will tell us how many
concurrent connections the maximum can
occur in the connections from the time
we enable the method that can ever
recorded if that can be supported by
cloud net so after we I find the top
talkers and qualify if they're a good
candidate to clot net then we ask
ourselves the third question how to
migrate from using other night devices
into cloud net with a minimum service
impact so we choose to enable cloud net
on a per subnet basis and also once we
enable the cloud net for that particular
subnet then it's up to our development
team to remove the net tag at their pace
whenever they're ready to migrate into
cloud net once they remove the net tag
what's the impact to the existing
traffic for the existing connections
when you switch from nach to the cloud
net it will send a reset so for the type
of workload we have the traffic we have
is it's nearly like not detectable for
this transition
so with the so it turns out that to
migrate to cloud net is actually fairly
manageable but we're still trying to
figure out how can we do capacity
planning and ongoing capacity planning
so that we can take a more proactive
position and that is true not only for
that but also that's true for all the
other services we manage in DCP so now
after one year in DCP what should we do
what should it be focusing on of course
we pop a bottle of champagne first and
then after that we know that we need to
monitor quota and the resource usage the
reason being is that once we situate it
in to DCP the workload continue to grow
so we have to keep our eye and have a
good visibility into all the quota usage
and resource usage so that we can be
more proactive and also we need to focus
on optimizing our workload not only just
for cosmic optimisation but also for
service performance optimization and we
start to have more and more asked from
different development teams where they
have their own self manager the
infrastructure where they want to be
able to connect into DCP directly and
from for example now we are working on
the project where we will utilize the
Hong Kong the new Hong Kong region
offered by TCP for connectivity and
better connectivity into our
infrastructure in mainland China and
also we invest very heavily on
automation we invest on automation for
the purpose to have a self-service
approach for our web developers so that
they can either it really fast rather
than you know create a request and wait
for us to do the request and also for
the purpose of reduced operational cost
and also speak from the experience I
think public cloud technology evolved
very fast and also Google released new
features on the regular basis
so it's always something that we need to
keep informed on the new features and
new product and reevaluate reevaluate
our architecture to ensure that we can
meet the future growth needs so this is
our four other network teams focus after
the migration and Davis you interact
with many other customers do you want
anything else to to add anything else
here yes absolutely
thanks serial so one as Ariel mentioned
earlier right carefully monitor your
quotas so these quotas are present or to
prevent abuse of a platform as well as
for to protect you from unforeseen usage
usages right so there are two kinds of
quotas raid quotas which get reset maybe
every day maybe every minute depending
on the API here calling there's also the
resource code house which is essentially
like a VM count or project which doesn't
get reset so you you need to carefully
monitor and proactively request for
quota increases because depending on
your resource it does take time for
approval second when you so we are at
next a lot of product announcements
happening this week do test it out and
provide feedback so that we can quickly
eye trait over it also you have if for
the existing products today there are
there is a platform for you a platform
in which you can essentially file issues
and feature requests so that if you feel
certain products should behave
differently or does not have a supported
functionality well you can use this so
this is kind of how it looks like it's a
public page and you just need to
determine the component and if there's
already an issue that there you wanna
file and if it already exists upward it
so that more eyes are looking at it
finally for your favorite GC P products
book market example is well here's cloud
not maturing from beta to GA in number
38 last year
and finally if
you have we continuously strive to
expand our do of the regions globally
right and well as you mentioned we do
have region in Hong Kong
which is Asia is too so if you have
queries on accessibility of users to GCP
resources like accessibility of users in
China to GCP resources well there are
inter connectivity options we have the
China specialist team sitting in this
room right here or you can come talk to
me later about it - all right thanks
Davis so I hope this experience sharing
that we had between Google and unity has
helped you out to think beyond the
obvious and we do hope that while you
are planning your migration you don't
keep these points in mind if you're
already in would be I mean you could
probably evaluate it and see if that's
the right thing to do or there any other
things that you can add to what the
current architecture that you have if
you do need some help in getting your
pipes in order please let us that give
us a shout out we'll be more than happy
to let you know our experiences or we
can definitely connect your two teams
who can help you out
[Music]